the eyes to the right 286 the nose to
the left 344
so the noes have it the noes have it
once again a vote in Parliament and once
again a defeat for the government for
the third time Prime Minister Theresa
Mayes brexit plan failed
Mr Speaker I fear we are reaching the
limits of this process in this house
this house this house has rejected
No Deal it has rejected no brexit on
Wednesday it rejected all the variations
of the deal on the table and today it
has rejected approving the withdrawal
agreement alone unless something changes
Britain is now set to leave the EU on
April 12 may could request a new vote an
extension or even cancel breaks it or
call a new referendum but it's uncertain
how long she will remain Prime Minister
leading conservatives are already
positioning themselves to replace her
and the opposition also wants her to
leave mr. speaker the house has been
clear this deal now has to change there
has to be an alternative found and if
the Prime Minister can't accept that
then she must go not at an indeterminate
date in the future but now the EU had
anticipated May's defeat and will hold a
special summit on April 10th just two
days before Britain may now have to
leave the Union without a positive
choice the default option will be the
New Deal which has become more likely it
was never our scenario but you 27 is now
prepared
that would actually be good news for
these people brexit supporters were
poised to celebrate their departure from
the EU on Friday but now it's doubtful
they'll get what they want we had a
democratic vote it needs to count we
wanted brexit today we want this lot to
agree to get us out as soon as possible
and that they are gonna betray us yet
again I fear No Deal
new elections a second referendum no
brexit in fact anything is still
possible the British Parliament has once
again voted and once again still nothing
is clear so what does this mean for
brexit let's try to get some clarity now
DWC charlotta Potts is in London for us
good morning to you the UK was supposed
to be waking up today the day after
brexit newly exited from the EU instead
we have no clarity on how or even if
brexit will happen first off how are
people there reacting to that well the
mood is quite somber this morning in
London you just saw those leaf
supporters they were protesting here on
the streets yesterday demanding an exit
from the European Union immediately no
matter at what costs they even want to
leave without a deal and then you have
those pro Europeans that also came out
yesterday that are hoping now that the
momentum is finally there for a second
referendum or for even no brexit at all
and then there are those that are quite
tired of this political infighting
that's been going on over the past three
years since the referendum and they just
want the country to get on with it no
matter how yeah just just get on with it
well speaking of getting on with it
recent maize deal has now been defeated
three times is it dead or could she get
on with it could we see the Prime
Minister bringing this deal to MPs for
yet another attempt well there seems to
be still some life in a Teresa may has
proven incredibly incredibly resilient
in this whole process so she might want
to try it to bring it back and
of parliament for a fourth time indeed
after three times defeat which would be
quite incredible and it doesn't look
like she will get the numbers and that
the majority will vote for her deal and
then we are looking at two options one
option would be that the UK indeed
leaves the European Union on April 12th
without a deal at all
that could have catastrophic
consequences for the country the people
the economy or Theresa May goes back to
Brussels and asks for another extension
for a longer extension where then the UK
would have to indicate and find some
clear path forward which could be a
second referendum for example or
remaining in the customs union now if
nothing changes before April 12th and
what about the possibility that the UK
would actually be forced to participate
in EU parliamentary elections well a lot
of people wouldn't like that here
especially those hardliners in the Tory
party but I think the more pressing
issue is about this whole No Deal
scenario because European leaders and
also leaders here in the UK have now
come out and said this scenario looks
more and more likely on Monday
Parliament is going to vote on a series
of alternatives here whether to for
example remain in a customs union or
hold a second referendum but if that
deadlock is not solved if there is no
majority found then we're looking at a
No Deal scenario on April 12th because
it's up to European leaders really to
grant that extension to the UK so it
could be two very very nerve-racking
weeks coming up here in the UK all right
Charlotte departs for us in London thank
you very much